- Yeah, I know what
expired milk taste like,
especially when you been
broke all your life.
(laughter)
- We're eating flavored almonds.
You like almonds?
- Uh, I mean, like, I don't hate it.
I like salted cashews.
- Yeah.
- Those are good.
- I eat almonds every day.
- You do?
- I do.
- For, like, fun?
(laughter)
- What is this?
- Hell yeah.
Especially almond joy.
- Yeah, I eat almonds,
but I'm not, like, obsessed with it.
- They seem like a healthy alternative.
- I like almond milk,
but I don't really eat almonds as nuts.
- Then you're not gonna like this.
Here we have honey butter,
which sounds amazing.
- I don't like honey that much.
- Really?
You're weird.
- You're weird.
- Let me look at how much sugar this has.
- One gram of sugar.
- Oh, one gram of sugar.
That's not bad.
- Here we go.
- Okay.
- It tastes like candy.
- Okay, I could actually have this,
like, all the time.
What're you making that face for?
- I was not expecting this haste.
- Originally it tasted like
a mix of honey and butter,
and then suddenly, it
had this kind of like
cheese aftertaste.
- Maybe it's because I don't like honey,
but it's very deep.
- It's strong, it's strong.
- Yeah, it spreads into your mouth.
- Mine tastes sugary though.
- Honey.
Honey is sweet.
Have you never heard of honey being sweet.
- Wasabi, I love wasabi.
- This is wasabi.
When you eat sushi,
I scoop it like it's green tea ice cream.
- Oh.
- So, like, I scoop it like this, watch.
- Like a big amount.
- Yeah.
- Oh, hell, no.
- We're Dominicans.
We don't eat spicy like that.
- I'm excited about this.
I feel like this is a
new way to eat wasabi
other than wasabi peas and sushi.
- It smells like a really good,
like, Korean junk food.
- One time I had my
little brother try wasabi
and told him that it was guacamole.
(laughter)
So this is, like, payback or some shit.
- Oh.
- Delicious.
- Um, I love it, it is so good.
- This is really good.
Perfect amount of spice.
- Yeah.
Like, wasabi peas are
way spicier than this.
I think it's really good.
- There's a kick.
- There's a kick, ain't it?
You're like, at first, you're like
"eh, it's not that bad."
Whoo!
- It tastes like wasabi peas
but actually a little bit better
because I prefer almonds over peas?
- I thought I would hate it,
cause, like, I only eat wasabi with sushi.
I don't know.
I'm into this.
- It wasn't spicy.
- It was like, there was this heat in it
and the heat is what, what got to me.
- I think I could eat this every day.
- Hmm.
- Yogurt.
Or, more known as yakult.
- Yakult is, like, famous in Asia.
I think Japan and Korea mostly.
- Yeah.
- Drinkable yogurt, but
it tastes really good.
- I'm trying to figure it out.
- It tastes like Fruit Loops milk.
It tastes like the milk--
- Like the milk is expired.
- Um, nah.
- It's a little questionable.
- It tastes exactly
like yakult with almond.
- Right, but I don't know if
they should go together, right?
- Yeah.
- It tastes, like, a little bit expired.
- Yeah, it does taste like expired milk.
- It's like you dip an almond in yakult
and let it sit there for, like, two hours.
- Yeah.
- And dry it up and then have you eat it.
- I love wasabi.
- Wasabi.
- Wasabi was by far the best.
I would eat that daily.
- I like the yogurt one.
Maybe I like expired milk.
- Someone's gotta have it.
- This wins.
It's not too sugary.
It's a different--
It's an acquired taste.
It's, like, a little different.
- I didn't think the wasabi
was disgusting or hideous
or nothing like that.
It was just a kick
because my taste buds
are not used to, like,
anything spicy or any heat.
- You want to be healthy
and still have a taste.
- Yeah.
- You got it.
- I'll eat the yogurt one.
It reminds me of my broke childhood.
(laughter)
(upbeat music)